I know that we have something in common  I have two kids we have three kids and  I'm just curious how I like it a  one-to-many what two would have been  fine  is that what you say to your third one  no we don't we don't bring it up not  around not within earshot it's a lot of  work be honest I don't know I have two  doesn't really three is that much harder  I mean first of all you've gone to zone  you know it's not man-to-man  right you're outnumbered yeah yeah you  know the problem with the third one you  still got the first two yeah I think  you're the best dad I  you know I see the month the holidays my  wife's doing a great job  I have my agent look after my kids